i mean it's such a hopeful ideology
really isn't it
this idea that for many of us we're in a
position now that we've never been in
before that our ancestors
even our parents weren't in so we can
now think about why am i here
how do i wish to spend my time what do i
want out of each day you know
so maybe your grandparents feel
laughable what you just gotta
find a way to make some money get food
on the table and have some shelter at
night so it is it is a lovely thought
because actually
many things that have happened in the
world over the past years including the
big lockdowns and the sort of
restrictions uh that were put in place
in 2020 they are
forcing a lot of these existential
questions to so many of us you know how
are we living our life what was i
really doing did i enjoy just constantly
chasing all the time
2021 finally out of the absolute
nightmare that was 20 20.
are you a new year's resolutions guy you
got any resolutions for this year
i used to be a resolution guy um
back in the olden days this year no
i haven't made any really i find
i find resolutions have
helped me in the short term in the past
but haven't really helped me in the long
term and i guess that's also what i've
seen
with many of my patients i'm not against
resolutions
right i get that everyone has got a
different approach different things work
for different people for sure but for
me i
think about values what are the values
i want to live my life by this year what
actions do i need to take
regularly that is going to help me
act in accordance with those values and
i guess
if i'm honest 2020 has probably shifted
things for me in the sense that
like for many people there was a lot of
reflection in 2020
um you know life came to a stop and
certainly the way many of us used to
live our lives
and remember in august i actually went
off social media for
18 days and
it was just incredible mate because in
those 18 days
once i'd got out of the habit of picking
up my phone and looking for the
instagram app which i'd actually deleted
from my phone
i really found a sense of calm and
sereneness
and i really started to tap into
what i thought not what the world around
me thought
like what do i really think about
these issues and it was it was it was
like
you know shutting out the noise from the
world
and allowing me to hear my inner voice
and i thought long and hard about my
values and what are the values by which
i
aspire to live my life and i thought
about things like
integrity uh compassion
uh creativity fairness i thought
you know family big value for me is my
family
i thought i was thinking about well are
your actions
consistent with these values are they
real values or are they aspirational
values
and so i've been doing a lot of that
kind of inner thinking over the past few
months and i think that's one of the
reasons why i've not set any resolutions
this year is because
i feel pretty content these days mate if
i'm honest i've been working hard on
myself
my health my well-being my thoughts my
mindset for a good 5 10 years now
and i feel that yeah there's a few
things i want to focus on this year for
sure
i've got a chart in my kitchen at the
moment as my kids do
and i've got three daily practices on
there that i'm committing to
and i thought long and hard because in
the past i would have put eight or nine
down
and i i was going to do one but i know
i'm quite confident with these three
so i've realized that if i do these
three things every day
i win the day i'm doing uh because
there's a temptation i think these days
to go online and say i could do that i
could practice martial arts i could do
breath work i could do meditation i
could do yoga
i could do strength training i've been
that person before so
you know that's a long-winded answer to
your question have i set any resolutions
no do i not agree with resolutions now i
think they can work
okay for some people but for me i'm at a
place where actually
this year at least have made zero
resolutions
i think that the end of the year
increasingly now as we see more
sophisticated goal planning and setting
strategies coming about
is more just a break point for people
it's just an opportunity for them to
check in and think about
okay i'm back at my parents girlfriends
the in-laws house whatever it might be
i was here this time last year what's
changed between last year
and this year it's an opportunity to
slow down and do a little bit of
reflection
so yeah i totally get that man like our
daily habits and actions
are a manifestation of the values that
we're supposed to be enacting right
they're the embodiment
of whatever those values are but if we
never slow down and take that time away
from social media like you mentioned
to actually reflect on what are our
values you're never gonna get there
what are the three uh the three daily
practices you're doing
so the three ones that i've decided on
at the moment and again
this may iterate this may evolve i may
reassess every month
uh i'm not gonna lock myself into the
prison that
oh i decided these three for the year
these have to be the three
for the entire year so they are 15
minutes of meditation
okay what's your what's your practice or
what's the support of choice with that
so there's a couple things to say about
this so i don't have a
particular formal practice that i do i
have tried
various methods over a number of years
uh whether it's via apps whether it's
sort of
learning tm when i was 14 when my mum
taught me when we were on holiday in
india and actually i thought this was a
load of rubbish at this
time man i wish i paid attention back
then um
but because now i would i would love to
go on a course and actually learn some
of these things properly i just wasn't
ready for it unfortunately at the age of
14
but what i have found over the past few
months is when i just sit there
in silence i'm able to access sometimes
i have to go through three or four
minutes of
noise but i can drop in now to quite a
calm
state without necessarily trying to do
anything but i must say that's come from
years of experimenting with different
forms
and i used to you know love using things
like the karma
and i'm not against that i think it
could be super helpful but for me
it's against just sitting there with no
tech with nothing
and just trying to you know accept
anything that comes up in my minds
now why 15 minutes because i'm a big
believer
that you don't need to make these things
that complicated
they don't need to take that long and
actually sometimes
we try and make them too hard and i have
done one minute meditation a day before
i've made deals with patients before to
say
what can you agree to what can you
commit to two minutes okay yeah
do two minutes a day every day i'll see
you in three weeks
but this is the i want to call it the
end stage
this is me along this journey for a
number of years
i have done the five minutes every day
i've done the 10 minutes every day
and for me i feel 15 minutes is just
pushing me a little bit
because after about 10 minutes i can get
a bit twitchy and i think well if i if i
make 15 minutes of commitment
i think i can manage it i think i'm
ready for it
and within a few weeks 15 will be my new
norm and maybe in fair but i might go to
20.
but maybe i'll six to 15. so 15 minutes
of meditation
five minutes of breath work uh is what
i'm
doing currently now i'm doing this new
spiral breathing thing that i've learned
from
this running coach who's been helping me
at the moment because
at this time last year i went on the
chris evans show to talk about my last
book and he challenged me on
air on virgin radio to do the london
marathon in 12 weeks with him and i
accepted even though i'm
you know at the time not really a runner
i'd do the odd 5k park run
um and so i got introduced to this
amazing
running coach in amisham called helen
hall and she is just incredible
now obviously that the marathon got
postponed and were you secretly thankful
about that
uh it was tricky because i do like a
challenge
and i was actually looking forward to
can i go from nothing to a marathon in
12 weeks
yeah i'd have enjoyed that challenge as
well yeah so i think part of me
relishes those sorts of things but at
the same time
i wasn't really ready for it and so when
it was me to whatever i thought okay
this gives me more time
to actually get ready for it and then
it's been postponed and it's due to
happen in october
so one of my universacom's goals for
this year is to do the london marathon
in october
now i'm very relaxed about it it may
happen
it may not happen whether it happens or
not i'm not going to suddenly have an
up or down of emotion it's simply okay
cool
i would like to do that and one thing
i've been doing with this running coach
is she's been helping me with my
diaphragm and my breathing so i've got a
few exercises that
um i'm working on at the moment and then
why i think that's so useful
around this idea of resolutions is that
that i don't have a resolution but i do
have a goal to do that marathon if it
comes
about so therefore i want to take daily
actions
that i know are getting money in the
bank for me that
when it is marathon time if it goes
ahead
well when i get to that start line i
know that i've done that five minutes of
breath work every day
that's getting my breathing better
that's getting my respiratory system
uh working more efficiently that is
going to help me in whatever i do
yes the marathon but it's always going
to help me in my life so
meditation uh breathing
and the third one at the moment and it's
not the usual one for me is affirmation
so one minute of affirmation so just
something positive to say each morning
to get me in the right mindset for the
day ahead
now if you'd asked me six months ago it
would be completely different right so
this is just
where i'm currently at and what feels
right to me
breathwork has been one of the favorite
additions that i've brought into my
routine
i know that we're both buddies with
brian mckenzie and then his
state app that um he was part of the
team that developed as a sponsor on the
show
uh anyone that wants to check out bit.ly
state wisdom and you can get it for free
for two weeks
um and it's just awesome man like i
challenge anybody to do
a good breath work session and tell me
that they don't feel a change
and i think that marrying with
meditation the challenge that you have
at getting people to do it is it's
inherently uncomfortable
you don't actually have a state change
sorry you don't have a trade change
immediately afterward
it's a lagging state change over time
whereas if you do
wim hof or if you do state app brian's
application there is no way that you
can't
say you don't feel different immediately
afterwards it's like a cup of coffee or
a cold shower
yeah absolutely and you know that's a
key part of
any behavior change is getting that sort
of emotion that positive emotion
immediately once it is done and you
don't always get that in meditation
sometimes the benefits of meditation are
at 2pm later on that day when you don't
react
um when someone cuts you up on the road
or
you know you don't react when your
partner says something to you that you
think ah
actually normally i react to that could
that be because i've been meditating for
the last few days do you know what i
mean so
um whereas breath work yeah you will
feel you do five minutes of him half
breathing
you know you can feel energized and
charged
afterwards and so i'm i'm very keen to
sort of emphasize as i've already said i
think that
me sharing that doesn't necessarily mean
that i think everybody should be doing
that
i've been kind of playing around and
experimenting and i think
it's i think it's on all of us yeah we
can take inspiration from people we
follow or people we read
but at some point you've got to start
taking ownership yourself and going
yeah that works for brian mckenzie that
works for chris that was wrong and
does that work for me except maybe yeah
but maybe hey you know what that one
just doesn't
vibe for me and you mentioned brian and
i love brian and his work i think it's
awesome and what i love about brian what
i particularly resonate with is
he his approach to breath work in the
body reminds
me a lot about my own approach with my
patients and that is
a very generalist perspective like brian
is familiar with
the vim hof breeding uh he's familiar
with uh
holotrip he's familiar with
mcewan's uh breathing is he's familiar
with buteyko breathing
and what i think brian does so
beautifully well is he is able to
combine
what is the right breathing technique
for this individual that wants
this goal rather than saying oh i'm a
proponent of vim hof breeding
or i do the buteyko method or i do this
method it's kind of like well
they all have pros and cons they all
have benefits
in the right situation and i love that
because
um you know i i spoke to brian on on my
show
i spoke to um james nestor um
patrick mcewen and then people are
asking well which one
is the best one and it's kind of like
yeah maybe you haven't made it clear but
that's kind of not the point for me it's
kind of like these are
all brilliant tools and actually i have
tried so
i can't remember which breeding
technique it was now but i've got an
aura ring
and you can do for about 10 minutes or
so you can
measure your heart rate variability and
you can see what happens and i've tried
different
breathing techniques and seen what
happens and some breathing techniques
that regarded as being
good for you actually they tank my heart
rate variability
and i've realized ah so maybe that's
just something for me to keep an eye on
maybe that's not the best one for me
in this current state um yeah so
so a few thoughts there from me the
thing that i think is interesting
that i really like about what's happened
with health and fitness probably over
the last i would say three years or so
maybe a little bit more but definitely
the last three years is this movement
toward a
minimum effective dose a much more sort
of realistic and simplistic view
of how people need to do health and
fitness i think that you're part of that
i would class james smith
as another one of them perhaps on the
more sweary side um
and what we're doing is there was a
period 10 years ago
all the guys that are listening who are
sort of in their early 30s will know
this bodybuilding.com forums
and you were desperately scouring
through whatever you could find like how
do i build biceps and no one really knew
no one really actually had any idea
taking some dudes
push-pull leg split off the other side
of the internet on a random forum from
some guy that lives in
dallas texas and you just go and do it
and see if it worked
whereas now all of that explore
situation where people have tried
oh should i be doing five three one
should i actually be doing higher reps
should i be doing cardio three times a
week
all of those uh opportunities that
people have had to
make new ground to kind of look at all
of these different tactics
has been synthesized and it's now i
think the goal of the generalist
as opposed to the specialist to actually
compile all of this together
like brian to look at all of the
different elements all of the different
breathing techniques how can you
synthesize it down that's why i love the
state app because it's only four
exercises
there's four different ones that you can
do and they're built on four different
pathways that brian obviously backs
so i go right okay that's simple there's
not unlimited customizability
and the same with the way that you put
your stuff across and especially james
smith as well like you know he's trying
to break things down to the
simplest possible terms like
just how easy can i make this and i
think what that's identified is that
compliance
is the number one indicator of how
effective a habit especially behavior
change diet fitness training
health is going to be if your habit is
so complex
and so convoluted and so hard to
understand that you either
don't get started on it or don't stick
to it then it can be the best training
plan in the world but it means [ __ ] all
what actually matters is can you create
a plan
that that person understands and sticks
to and if that's the if that's what you
can achieve
you will get results yeah no question i
think i think it's a very astute
observation
um simplicity is
is is key you know keep it simple stupid
there's that phrase isn't it ki double s
keep it simple stupid and it's
you see this over and over again this is
i think one of the reasons why
let's say we talk about you know the
dietary tribes
um you know let's say like low carb for
example low carb
can be a fantastic approach for some
people
um but it's not the be-all and end-all
for everyone
certainly that's from my clinical
experience is that the different
approaches work for different people
but i think one one of the good things
about it and other
dietary tribes it's there's a real
simplicity to it it's like okay when i'm
following
this way of eating i don't eat many
carbs right so it just
it just helps decision making when
you're faced with all these options like
i know i can't have that because i don't
do carbs
um you know i i'm not pro or anti-low
carb i use it with some patients
but i i don't identify as being in or
out of any one of these dietary cases
it's the uh
attraction of time restricted eating as
well right it's just
so simple yeah and again you know uh
professor sachin pandey from the salk
institute who's probably
the the leading researcher on time
restricted eating
he when i when i spoke to him said that
look you know they're trying to change
what people have eat has really been a
bit of a failure for the last 20 years
or so we've been trying that
maybe changing when people eat might be
a
simpler option and again for some of my
patients
yeah it's just they don't have to worry
so much about what they eat they go okay
i eat
every day from 8 a.m til 6 p.m and it
just simplifies their life down and they
know oh after six months no i don't eat
now
and again we need to find what are those
what are what are the right
rules that deeply resonate with us that
we feel yeah i can follow that
um you say minimum effective dose and
i think it's really interesting if you
look at behavioral science
research it's pretty clear that actually
the best way to make a habit stick in
the long term is to make it easy
uh professor bj fogg talks a lot about
this he talks about the motivation wave
so motivation comes up
motivation goes down many of us
particularly in january chris
we forget about the motivation wave we
assume
motivation is going to be limitless
for the whole year we go i'm going to go
spinning four times a week now
for the next year and for the first two
three weeks of january we may actually
go
but when real life gets in the way when
our motivation
starts to fall if something is difficult
to do
we won't do it we only will do it
like motivation and ability to do our
our sort of teammates when if motivation
is really high
yes you'll do something that's really
hard to do but in motivation it's low
it's got to be easy so rule number one
for me for behavior change
is you've got to make it easy um
and you know business understands this
so you know
amazon when amazon moves to one click
ordering a few years ago now
we don't know this for sure but
estimates say that their profits went up
by 300 million dollars
a year a year can you imagine if you
were the guy in the office that came up
with one click ordering
like euro yes you're at such a fat bonus
yeah you would hope so wouldn't you you
would you would hope so but they all do
it because it's kind of like instead of
four or five screens to put in card
details and expiry dates and stuff which
every
every single step you take as a reason
to pull out of that behavior
boom before you blink something's coming
the next day
and so you know rule number one is that
you've got to make it easy netflix you
should all do the same thing they roll
one video into the next video that is
not done by accident
that is done so before you realize it's
midnight i need to be up at six o'clock
for work
before you've had time to process that
you're straight into the next episode
and you're like oh man just one more
right and i'm not criticizing those
companies right
they're doing what they need to do
they're applying the best
behavioral change science for their
businesses
and i'm saying when it comes to our
health why do we throw that stuff out
the window why do we think it's got to
be about deprivation
punishment restriction let's follow some
of those rules make it easy
and the other rule that i i love talking
to people about is where are you gonna
put
that habit or that new behavior in your
day a lot of us don't think about that
we go i want to meditate or
i want to work out when and it's really
important because every
single behavior we do needs a trigger
right so the trigger could be
your memory oh i remember i've got a
call tonight with chris at 6 30 to
record this podcast
okay it works it just happens to be the
most unreliable trigger there is
uh the next best trigger is a
notification so i think on my phone
saying hey 630 you've got a call with
chris you need to be
on your mic with the studio lights on
and ready to go okay that's
better than your memory but the very
best trigger as shown by the research
is when you stick on that behavior that
new behavior onto an existing habit
because that habit is already wired in
and this is this is what i do chris so i
i've spoken about this before but i
think it's you know i i i always love
sharing this with people because it's
been so impactful for me
i make coffee every morning so when it
comes to the kitchen
i weigh out my coffee um because i'm
pretty precise with how i like it
what's your current blend what you're
having at the moment current blend is uh
a grumpy mule um
well i think it's a cropping mule it's
it's a it's an organic grumpy mule blend
i couldn't tell you the name
three ground are you grinding it
yourself no it is pre-grounds
it is pre-ground i i did think about
getting down that path but actually i
thought you know what i'm obsessive
enough about things
to add that in as well um
but i do weigh it out i weigh out 15
grams and then i pour 250 grams of
water oh so are you using a using a co2
bloom method are you allowing the carbon
dioxide to bloom out first
i don't go that far i don't go that far
my housemate my housemate's been on
furlough
all summer and has been really really
bored he started watching videos of this
japanese
barista that won the world coffee
championship
or something i came in came into the
kitchen and he's like
pouring the the filter paper he's
warming the filter paper up the glass
the the cafeteria gets warmed before as
well he went really really deep i think
it was excessive
the thing is right it's the right
addiction or the right behavior for the
right person i could have gone down that
route and i'm actually
slowly trying to unwind from coffee i'm
reducing how much i'm consuming because
i think it is my crutch that i tend to
see when i'm under pressure
um but the point is is that
i come down and i make it and then at a
time then for four minutes
a time that's how long i like it to
breathe and i've got this consistency i
know i like the taste i know a lot of
flavor like that in those
four minutes i have a workout every
morning
like in my pajamas i've i've got a
dumbbell and a kettlebell in the kitchen
sometimes i do a bodyweight workout
sometimes i'll do some kettlebell swings
but i make it easy right i don't have to
get changed i have to buy any equipment
i don't
find anything from anywhere i don't i
i'm in my pajamas
i have that set routine where the coffee
gets made i don't need a reminder to
make coffee i don't need my pa to phone
me
in the morning and say hey wrong and
don't forget you've got to make coffee
no that's that's an automatic behavior
so if i stick on my work out there
it means every single day and this has
been the case for
maybe about three years now i've hardly
missed a day is it
i have coffee every day i work out every
day only for five minutes
right but you can do a lot in five
minutes
one of the things that i've been
absolutely blown away by is how
impactful habit stacking can be
like my morning routine habit stack now
this year i've made the biggest leap
yet which is to try and roll my morning
routine straight into a morning session
of deep work
which would be around about two hours um
but including my morning routine it's
like three and a half to four hours
and today was like everyone's done this
it's the fourth of monday the fourth of
january
everyone's new year's resolutions have
like been delayed from
friday the first until monday the fourth
which is kind of hilarious
but um and i'm such a huge advocate of
trying to give people that beautiful
unencumbered time on a morning
i find it like the best part the most
productive part of my day
and over time you can build up and just
continue to add on
move from that system to thinking to
that system one thinking
and start to automate those habits now
if you were told after three years of
doing it that you weren't allowed to
work out while your coffee was brewing
you get fidgety
and you'd feel weird and you'd be like
i'm sick of this like i don't know what
to do like i'm
supposed to pick the kettlebell up or
throw the dumbbell around and over time
this is how you see these people who
have unbelievably well disciplined lives
from the outside
but to them it's just automated they've
just slowly built this up
over time and they've managed to drill
what to you looks incredibly precise and
well thought out
but to them has just been a series of
very small behavior changes over time
yeah yeah i think i think it's a great
point to make
um we look at the end
product or the end version of what we're
seeing and we go wow have they done all
that but we didn't realize it was
probably 10 years in the making of
small 1 improvements
very much like that 15-minute meditation
thing for example that i do each morning
now
i wasn't going to be able to stick to
that even two years ago that was
that was too much for me i had to start
small and build up in five minutes each
day
and build in these habits and really
understand myself a lot better
um i yeah i mean someone asked me
recently
on my podcast about um
how do you get so much done right which
is really interesting for me because
i guess from the outside the person who
asked that question
has a perception that well how are you
getting so much done you're seeing
patients you
release a podcast each week you're
releasing a book every year
you've got two young kids you know what
what's the secret
and it's really interesting because to
me i was kind of like
yeah what is the secret and i i
struggled a little bit to think about
what it was because to me
i do have quite a disciplined life but
that discipline is a bit of a cliche it
does give me freedom it gives me
what i need and i think for me it was
when i when i had kids that things
started to change to me
and i tell you why i'm so transformative
for me in terms of my routine is
my son has always got up early even when
he was like really really young
and i like getting up early but i like
more than
anything time to myself each morning
before
the rest of the household rises i i i've
always been a morning person i
love that quiet time and i soon realized
wow if i'm gonna get up before my son i
need to go to bed earlier and wake up
earlier
right i was getting up silly early at
one point but i love it if i'm getting
up at five o'clock
i love that one hour in the morning
before anyone comes down where i can
you know do some meditation have a
coffee have a little workout do some
stretching
um do some reading i've got a few books
that are kicking around that i keep
in my living room like three or four i'm
always changing them and
i'll i will always sit with my coffee
and reads
you know for 10 or 15 minutes just
something positive something that gets
me thinking
every morning and i find when i do that
when i've nourished myself physically
mentally and emotionally every morning
not only am i a better human being not
only am i a better father a better
husband a better doctor
i also get a lot done right when i'm
writing
i i go straight for my morning routine
into writing and if i get a good three
hours writing done then
writing wise i'm done for the day that
is so much more valuable to me than
actually trying to start writing at 11
p.m and still slogging away 8 p.m
those eight hours are nothing compared
to a really good three hours first thing
in the morning
so and i'm really disciplined with my
time in the sense that
if it's dinner time and i'm with my
family my phone is nowhere in sight i'll
leave it in another room and i'm trying
my
best to be really present with the kids
and so you know how do i get so much
done i i don't really know
didn't really know how to answer that
apart from just share the things i do i
i
absolutely will prioritize sleep
like that i know when i sleep well
everything is better the following day
sleep is something i prioritize solitude
is something i prioritize when i get
these things
i feel i can get a lot of things done um
but also i think there's also a
perception from the outside of what
someone else's life is like
you know i'm a busy guy just like anyone
else you know i've got
lots of work commitments i've got family
i've got an elderly mother
nearby who needs looking after like what
i
post on social media what people see of
me in the media
is just one small portion of my entire
life but
an assumption is made on what i share
that that is my entire life but it
really isn't i'm
very intentional yes i share a lot of
myself but there's plenty i do not share
on social media
plenty i keep reserved and it's just for
me my family and my friends
well do we not all of us see our own
failings
from a front row seat right from the
outside looking in it might look like
you've completely got your life sorted
but you'll struggle not using your phone
too much you mentioned before i had to
go so far as to delete the app and to go
cold turkey for 18 days these are
challenges that we all
that we all have the difference is if
you've built up slowly over time if
you've constructed a routine that's
robust and has a nice foundation to it
your worst day will be better than
someone who hasn't done any of that
stuff's best days
so this is something i actually wanted
to ask to ask
let's invert your day you've talked
about what you do to make sure that you
have a good day
what could you do that would ensure that
you had the worst day what are the
habits or the actions that you take
that if you do them you end up wrecking
everything
yeah and that's a great question okay i
like that
how can i make sure i have a really bad
day tomorrow
okay i could do skype calls in the
evening
[Laughter]
no i'll um okay
it was fun but actually what's really
interesting is
me having a bad day tomorrow
starts at about 5 p.m the day before
right so if i
if i work late into the evening so if
i'm still wired
in my brain even at 8 pm which is late
for me because i do get up early
that can affect how long it takes me to
switch off and then fall into
a nice deep relaxing sleep how can i
make sure tomorrow day tomorrow
is bad i could after this call
i could get uh some christmas some
biscuits
and go and put netflix on and
still be watching it at one am i can
still be doing that
and i would enjoy myself i'd love
watching i'd love in the moment that
feeling
that i wouldn't sleep well i'd still
wake up early because my body clock is
totally locked in so i don't use it
alone but i will still wake up at five
tomorrow morning
i'll feel a bit cranky my meditation
won't be very good
i'll be a bit ratty with the kids i
won't be as
calm and as present over breakfast
tomorrow
um those are the kinds of things that i
could do
this evening that would ensure i had a
bad day tomorrow
and to break it down eating late for me
is a big one i i've seen this and i've
tracked it as well that if i eat
within two hours of going to sleep for
me it's not the same for everyone but
for me
i just don't sleep as deeply so i may
fall asleep
i may sleep for the same amount of time
but i don't feel as well rested the
following day
uh for me i know i'm pretty sensitive to
screens before beds
again i've tracked that so it's very
hard to resist sometimes i have a rule
that i
don't i try it's not a rule because i
don't always manage to
hey it's an aspiration to not take my
phone into my bedroom
if it comes into the bedroom i really
struggle to not look at it
so i tend to charge it in the kitchen or
charge it in another room
um but also that one hour before beds
you know what i do then you know do i
amp up my brain with thinking about
things and
uh consuming things either on social
media or on twitter
or online or the you know on television
that gets me wide or is it is it kind of
like a switch off
that one hour before bed for me is
golden if i
really can switch off no screens
dim lighting maybe reading it makes it
it's probably the most important error
in my day in many ways because if i get
that hour right the next day will fly
and if i get that
that hour wrong i can really pay for it
the next day
yeah i would say the hour before bed and
the hour upon waking
are the two most important for me as
well i don't know man
like the one thing that i fear
with creating a routine that i love so
much and i rely on as much as i do now
and every year
right i'm adding stuff onto it it gets
longer it gets bigger i'm now trying to
actually make the first basically until
midday
part of a morning routine and i guess
that there's no there's no chance for
variety at the moment we're all locked
down in our houses right um
but one of the fears that i have one of
the challenges that i come up against
is when part of that falls away
avoiding a catastrophic tumble down
right that's it
i've missed my meditation everything's
out of the window now or if i do end up
sleeping in uh not getting to sleep
until late for whatever reason maybe
because i'm recording maybe because i
just have a bad night's sleep
not waking up in the morning and
thinking well i've only slept for six
hours because my whoop strap tells me
i've only slept six hours oh
i i looked at my phone before 9am which
is one of the rules that i'm not
supposed to do
you actually can end up almost becoming
superstitious
like the old football player that used
to have to put his left sock on that his
right side on and double
not his laces in this particular way you
can almost have a
domino effect in terms of being so
overly reliant on your routine that as
soon as one thing falls off that you get
very catastrophic thoughts down the line
i've definitely been girls with that in
the past
um like it was all or nothing
but let's not forget as well that the
point of the routine is to be more
robust
more anti-fragile not less
yeah you're right and i think it's
something you're sharing something i
i've certainly struggled with in the
past i've got to say that's changed in
the past year for me
but i and i'm trying to sort of unpick
why that might be
is i've done a lot of work
with a therapist about my upbringing my
childhood you know these certain
patterns of behavior that i have and
where they may have come from
and i think for a lot of my life
i've felt good about myself
only when i had external validation of
what i had done
if other people say you're doing well
hey you're doing great even if inside
you if you're dying doesn't matter
people are saying it's good oh it's good
and i've really unpicked where a lot of
that has come from you know i
i believe that actually um
as a kid i was under the impression that
in some ways you're only really worth
something when you've achieved something
that's good and i think therefore
your identity becomes pretty fragile
actually you're very much a prisoner to
the world around you you're a prisoner
to
what other people think and what other
people say
and i've had to really go in and
understand that because
okay in 2015 i had my own bbc one prime
time show
called doctor in the house which runs
for two seasons which has been watched
by five million people a week
you suddenly are putting yourself out
there and with social media the way it
is
hey people can say whatever they want
about whatever they want whether true or
not
and i really found that difficult
because initially it was like
i don't really understand i mean where
some of these crystals have come from
i've just helped
all these families with complex health
problems who've
not got better seen gps and smashers in
the past and
without fail i've got almost all of them
either fully better or significantly
better in six weeks
just by making or helping them make
changes their lifestyle
i was like why why why is this one
percent of people attacking me and
saying that you didn't do it the right
way you didn't do this
now you can either let that bury you or
you can go okay this is an opportunity
to learn here this is obviously to
understand why am i
so bothered by what other people are
saying and being in the media and
having a public profile of sorts of five
years
in some ways as the best crucible to
learn because you
either sink or you swim you baptism of
fire yeah you either sort this stuff out
or you become a very unhappy individual
who doesn't feel good about themselves
and i've had
moments like that i remember when the
second season of doctrinal star said
first episode i think i didn't sleep for
a week properly after that i was so
affected by what people were saying
even though it's the one of the proudest
things i've ever done in my entire
career professional but also personal
life
and i understood once you unpick where
that comes from and you
you come to terms with it you start to
really
become more at peace with who you are so
i don't really have that all or nothing
mentality anymore that i used to
whereas in the past it's like oh you
failed you know you said you're gonna
meditate
move do a bit of mindset do this didn't
do it today forget it
forget it let's just go and get some
chocolate and crisps
the old me might have done that but i i
would like to say it's been about 12
months now certainly the last six months
weather has really been a noticeable
shift chris
uh with me uh i think if we had done
this interview
two years ago and you said you made any
resolutions i said yeah absolutely here
are my five resolutions
right it's really interesting nobody's
really asked me that for a long time so
i guess during this conversation with
you i'm kind of processing that thinking
that's interesting that i haven't made
any resolutions this year
and i think it comes down to the fact
that i'm just more comfortable in my own
skin i understand
that my worth as a human being is not
dependent on whether i meditate every
morning or not
right i still you know i've come to
terms with the facts now
not come to terms with i i like the
person i see
when i look in the mirror each morning i
i actually really like myself now for
who i am warts and all and i've got to
say mate and i don't if you feel the
same way
with your podcast but having my own
podcast
i think has been one of the best things
i have done for my own personal
well-being
because i'm very raw and open and honest
on it and i feel just by
sharing myself not trying to curate an
image of who i am
really sharing every aspect of me
you think what can people criticize it's
kind of like i i share the things i
struggle with i share
what i'm not so good at i share it all
so it's kind of like
you've always taken that away from
other people but also from yourself
you're like oh no i am an
imperfect human that's okay right do you
know what i mean and so i kind of feel
i feel in a really good place these days
but it has not been
easy getting here um and so
coming back to what you were talking
about is i don't feel that sense of
failure anymore if i stop for a few days
i don't play the old record which is and
you're a failure you can't stick to this
stuff
it's like oh oh you know what it was
really busy
um i needed to help my mom kids were
busy at school
i didn't really go to bed on time okay
that's cool i can change that tomorrow
so that
that is a very noticeable shift in me
and it's very very recent
man i'm really happy to hear that it's
like so beautiful to find that you've
taken something that perhaps once would
have been a
a difficulty or a vice of that sort of
personal lambasting that very negative
in a monologue and that you've managed
to
align that with the lifestyle that
you've got now i think that's
like a really really great change that
you could have made
i wonder how many people have been
thinking about this so much recently
um i wonder how many people that are
that taipei's go-getters that are on the
personal development and the
self-creation growth journey
i wonder how many of those people are
motivated by the fact that inherently
they don't like the person that they see
in the mirror
like you can either run away from
something you don't like or run towards
something that you
do and i would guess that
a significant minority and maybe even
the majority
is actually running away from a
situation that they don't want
i think you're spot on i think it's the
majority actually
and you know if i had to guess i'd say
it's the majority because i think
in some ways that dissatisfaction that
internal dispatch
with who they are in many ways provides
the drive
to overcome that again no i am someone
i'm going to show you with this level of
success
with this level of income with this
level of whatever it is
i'm going to show everyone around me
that i am worth something
that i'm not worth less but the problem
is
i think that can work up to a certain
point
and then it can start to come really
really toxic and i i
have the question that haven't cracked
it in my head
that is it possible
to gain those really high levels of
success
or what society defines as being
successful i should say
because that can be very very different
than what actually what success can
really mean to us on an individual level
it's like
can we really achieve that without some
real
inner demons that we're trying to
overcome i think about this with
athletes a lot i think about
you know tiger woods or you know all
kinds of pro athletes who've gone
and done inhumane or seemingly
uh superhuman um feats
and actually you know michael jordan
interesting you know when you when you
watch the new
um well it's not you anymore the series
the last dance on netflix and
you know and that story when he was was
at the hall of fame a couple of years
ago where he goes up
and then he almost just shows how much
he is this anger and hatred and sort of
he's had to hold on to all these years
to be that good or certainly that's my
perception of what i've been reading
about say
it's so interesting that would he have
been that
great universal commerce without that
man not at all not at all i i think
there's absolutely no way that he could
have done
and i think when especially in sport and
sports a good example of it
the conditions for success in sport are
very tightly defined
it doesn't matter if tiger woods is the
most miserable
poor self-hating anything man on the
planet
if he gets the ball in the hole with
less hits than the other guy
he's the best golfer in the world so the
the
particular judgments the parameters that
we use are so tightly defined that it
doesn't matter
and anything that you do outside of the
sport
which actually assists you in the sport
means that you're going to out-compete
the people that are around you i'm not
sure if you know much about tiger woods
childhood
and the way that his dad i i do i i
i've been fascinated with tiger for the
last 15 years and i
read everything about him i'm he's
probably my dream podcast guest but who
wouldn't like him to be target i would
love
tiger if you're listening if you if
you're listening get get get on wrong
on twitter but i mean man like i heard a
story i think it was
in um one of ryan holliday's books
talking about the things that his dad
used to say to him
so his dad used to call him the n-word
used to say that he was
like be outwardly racist to him did you
hear that he used to have an
uh a safe word like people have during
rough sex
he used to have a safe word that was
called enough and they referred to it as
the e-word
and his dad would say to him look you
know if you can't take this if you don't
think you're good enough then just say
the word
and i'll stop and he never once said it
and you think that is
i mean is it child abuse it probably
would be certainly in today's
in the way that it looks at it today if
you had a patient a young
11 year old fledgling golfer come to you
and say
dr chatterjee uh my dad's being overtly
racist to me
and and forcing me to play golf and
doing all this stuff it's
only in the light of what he's achieved
that we're able to even see any tiny
little bit of perspective or sort of
justification for that
and really i don't know i i'd love i'll
tell you what the first question that
i'd
not maybe not the first one to be a bit
heavy to open with but um
to ask tiger would you rather have not
won everything that you won and not have
the programming that inevitably will
have carried over
from your upbringing or is the is the
juice worth the squeeze
yeah absolutely mate the same same
question
that i have in my head for him you know
was it worth it is it worth it and i
think there's a wider point there about
this definition of success right because
we look up to people like tiger now i'm
a tiger fan
right now explain what i mean by that is
i don't think that you know as a sports
fan growing up i found tiger intensely
fascinating who i mean lots of you know
i'm not unique in that regards
but as someone who grew up to an
immigrant family in the uk you know my
parents were indian immigrants came over
my dad came over in the 1960s
you know golf wasn't something that
featured for me it's not something my
parents played it's not something in
their
network golf was not played i
as a uh you know from an immigrant
family in the uk
i don't think i would have played or be
interested in golf if tiger woods didn't
exist there was something about tiger
that suddenly made everyone from
all walks of life from all different
colors and races suddenly
interested in the spores of golf
and then when tiger sort of goes off the
rails and it all comes out
right you know there was this huge
disappointment in tiger from the media
from his fans but then when you look at
his story and his child did you go hold
on a minute
was any of this really a surprise of
course
this was going to happen when you look
at his childhood no girlfriends no
social lives schooled from the
age of what from out of the womb to be
the number one golfer in the world
apparently
um you know his dad you know didn't
really want a kid at that age anymore
and so
tiger's in a high chair and just
watching his dad hit golf balls all day
and then suddenly
you know he pops out at some point and
actually can hit a golf club himself you
know
it's golf must have held such
a powerful emotional pull for him in
terms of
well i can't get attention from my dad
all he does is hit this golf club man i
want to do that as well so i can connect
with dads
but as you say racist abuse because he's
trying to train
tiger it says when you get up there in
those tournaments you're going
into a white sports people are not going
to like you they're going to throw abuse
at you
i am training you to be able to deal
with that and then you think about all
the criticism where
tiger is you know in the final round of
the major people say he's ignoring them
and he's not
signing autographs and not doing things
but actually the guys are trained
assassin
you know he would say in interviews that
i don't hear
the noise i don't hear what people are
saying like in that final 18 holes of a
major
in his prime he's just in the zone he's
got one goal and that is
next shot get the golf ball where he
wanted to go get in the hole
as he says get the world get the w that
was what it was always about for him
and so i'm fascinated that when he wins
the masters a couple of years ago
after that huge time when he won nothing
there was something different about him
in his interviews he was
you know his his shoulders were
he was smiling he was cracking jokes it
was like a different target it was like
a it was like a tiger to me
who had faced his demons who you know he
said an interview you know i i said to
my kids i said the reason
um daddy doesn't live in mummy anymore
is because daddy made some big big
mistakes
and that's why we're not together and to
hear
someone like tiger who i think has been
trying to never show
any weakness to start
opening up i wonder how that masters
victory
felt to him compared to all his other
majors in the past because he feels like
he's someone who
went to that extreme he had to stare his
demons in the face the world's
media are literally printing things
about the
most intimate details of the entire life
i challenge any one of us
to like that process and to actually not
be harmed by that process you know it's
we're very good at judging other people
and going oh man he's really let us down
really well why did we put him on such a
big pedestal in the first place maybe in
society
that's one of the major problems we have
is that we're idolizing
people who actually achieve as you said
that tight metric of sporting success
but maybe you know aren't the best
husband or the best father or the best
whatever
right we're we're idolizing these people
but what if and this is something i
reflect on in 2020
well what if we started to define
success a little bit differently what if
success was
how much time this year did i spend with
the people who i really value
how many meals this year did i spend
or did i have with my children and my
wife and i wasn't away
what if we started to look up to people
who actually achieved those things
because
if that was what we are aspiring to as a
society
well maybe suddenly the whole the
society suddenly starts to look
differently straight away but if if if
we're looking up to is your tiger woods
is your michael jordan are those the
posters we have on our walls or
young boys have on their walls well
actually
is that not the inherent problem or is
that not one of the inherent problems in
the way society is set up
maybe we're idolizing the wrong people
man it's a really deep point and it's
something i don't know
i've read far too much evolutionary
psychology over the last year to hope
that that would ever happen
i think that we're inevitably going to
stratify out into hierarchies and those
hierarchies are almost always going to
be on
socialized measures of success
externalized measures of success
i can't look at you and see just how
mindful you are
see her just how satisfied you are see
how just how loved you are and how
loving you are and how awakened and
aligned and present and all the rest of
the stuff but i can
probably see how many followers you've
got on twitter and i can guess at your
net worth and i can do other things like
those are the games that people play
they play status games and the goal
for almost everybody is to completely
step out of that game
but the problem is that most of the
things that we do in life
that are deemed as successful and we're
mimetic creatures right we do what the
people around us do we live in tribes
most of the things that we do are
reliant on other people
affirming our sense of worth
and that's what we get but um i don't
know man i
i certainly think that increasingly now
this
more western version of mindfulness this
sort of awakened aligned mindful content
and
the ability to be present and people
like naval ravicant is a perfect example
of this
someone who is winning at the game
and also not caring about playing like
he's somebody who has gone through that
process
and it reminds me i keep talking about
this his dark materials the trilogy by
philip pullman it was
my favorite set of books when i was a
kid and in this set of books
the um big story arc for one of the two
main
protagonists is the journey from
unconscious competence
to conscious incompetence and then to
finally to conscious competence
so that's what we talk about with tiger
that you have this
person who is an absolute assassin a
total trained killer
as soon as he's out on the t but
is doing it all totally unaligned
without having managed to absorb or work
out any of the other stuff that's going
on in his life
and then the journey that he really
needs to go on is not to become the best
in the world it's to become happy with
himself
yeah and to actually fully internalize
all of these things and to work through
and similar to you you know you've
managed to get yourself to a
prime time bbc two-season show
and yet if you two years ago hadn't
meditated there would have been a voice
in the back of your head saying oh
like wrong and that's that's another
reason why today's gonna suck or why
you're
worthless today or why you haven't done
this that any other like
that is the journey it's not about that
externalized
socialized metrics of success it is
about how happy you can be just being
you
it is but it's the it's it's often the
hardest journey to make
it's the hardest thing to see i'm so
conscious you know my kids are
a ten-year-old boy and an eight-year-old
girl and i talk about this stuff with
them you know
every breakfast time it's like you know
this is daddy's philosophy lesson for
the morning and we talk about this stuff
because you know
the truth is i never spoke about this
stuff when i was a kid i
you know as i mentioned you know my
parents were
were immigrants to the uk and their
metric of success is we're going to work
really really hard
and give our kids a better life than we
had
and their way of doing that was sending
us to good schools making sure that we
got
a's and everything so that actually we
would then succeed
in inverted commas and you know
not have to face the hardships that they
faced right and i love and respect my
parents for that
the problem is or one of the downsides
of that is you think your only worth is
when is when you're getting straight a's
and when you're top of the class
and when um you're achieving those
things and if you don't
you kind of feel like oh well what does
that mean about me what is my identity
then if i'm not that guy who's top dog
and it kind of
it's i think as i said before for me i
feel i've had the luxury in the
the in many ways the luxury of
the public profile because the scrutiny
you then put yourself
under it is sink or swim you either sort
this stuff out and i know lots of people
in media now and i think there's a huge
amount of fragile egos
in media who actually get their sense of
self-worth from
the perception from the public but on
the inside
there's some very unhappy people and i
say that with compassion i'm not judging
i'm genuinely not judging what i say
that i'm saying this is just what i've
observed
and i feel that actually as you say it's
that alignment isn't it that alignment
between
who you are internally and what you're
doing externally when we can bring that
into alignment that's calm
that's peace that's contentment
can you imagine if there was a social
network some sort of
social media where the follower count
was actually based
on how virtuous and how much of a a life
filled with integrity and presence
and alignment with your actual values
and what's good for the world
if that was the metric like i would go
as far as to say that i think it would
probably almost be inverted
that the people who end up winning at
the absolute extremes
are also the people who probably ha
would have the lowest score
in terms of that i'm saying this is
someone who's been on
take me out and love island and blue
tick on twitter and free charcoal
toothpaste
you know all the big things and i know i
know it for
a fact i know it from first-hand
experience
that the people who are applauded by
easy wins
and for being someone not doing
something most of them are miserable
yeah i don't disagree i i see that a lot
and
it would be interesting to see if we did
invert that what would actually
what would actually happen but as you
say you know when you study evolutionary
psychology you think well
could it be that way you know are we
wired that way as humans is this just
not the way
we have been built for so many years but
as i say that we have be built because i
i'm an optimist i do believe
that there is the possibility of change
i do believe like i i know mention a lot
about
children but for me and i know it's
quite an obvious thing to say but as a
as a parent you know having having kids
has really changed
who i am and what i value in my life you
know suddenly
you just can't be yourself abs as
self-absorbed or into yourself
as you might have been pre-kids because
as you know people who are relying on
you who
who are looking up to you and the the
probably the biggest lesson i've learned
in 10 years of being a dad
is that kids don't do
what you tell them to do they do what
they see you doing
and that's been a huge motivation for me
to
you know kind of sort this stuff out
it's kind of like i don't want to
pass on this baggage onto my children
and wait till they're 40 to start
unpicking this you know uh and i talk
about these concepts that i talk about
on my podcast i'm talking about
you today with the kids and you know
what they kind of get it mate
i kind of genuinely feel a lot of this
kids actually can get a lot of this but
it's interesting to see
what happens with society and schooling
and how it starts to condition a lot of
this
out of them and it's something that i
really struggle with as a parent it's
like well
i'm trying to instill certain values and
i and ideas
and philosophies or i shouldn't say in
still
i'm trying to have a conversation i
don't want to instill them in my kids i
want them to be
free to choose how they want to behave
how they want to engage with the world
but i
i love the thoughts of having these
conversations with a 10 year old boy and
an eight-year-old girl and hearing what
they have to say and often i'm like
oh man i just learned that at 43.
you guys are kind of getting this
already this is this is pretty cool i
hope that stays with you
and you don't have to re-learn or learn
for the first time as i am in my early
40s
man i think that's a really interesting
point um firstly having
more frictionless information access
means that now we're not partitioned off
based on where you are in the world or
the religion you have or the upbringing
you have
everybody has free access to the entire
history of humanity's knowledge
so what that should mean or what that
could mean from an optimistic standpoint
is an evolution of ideas
should end up with what people value
rising to the top
i think if i'm being an optimist which
i'm not usually
not usually on but i will be this time i
don't want to go back to the status
playing games that i used to play
sometimes i fall into them but i know
that the values that i want to pass on
to my children when i have them
and the way that i want to lead the rest
of my life is to do with the
internalized scorecard not the
externalized one
and that will make me happier so i'm not
going back to the old game even though i
might fall into it sometimes
so if i then pass that on to my kids and
that game
in the evolution of ideas beats the
internal scorecard beats the external
cor
scorecard every single time so
over time this should infect society
i also think that because uh the bottom
of maslow's hierarchy of needs
has now been fixed we're actually given
the opportunity because we're not
fighting for air and water and food and
shelter and warmth
we're actually given the chance to think
about these more abstract higher level
goals
and think about what do i want to be who
do i want to become how should what does
it mean to live a good life
what does it mean to live a good life is
the source of an existential crisis
but also a really luxurious position to
be in like to be able to ask that
question means that you have
so much freedom because all of the stuff
that your ancestors
for the last two million years have been
fighting over has been sorted
so perhaps we are at the inflection
point maybe the
free movement of ideas will allow people
to infect
in a good way their children and from
that
not have to worry and scrabble and fight
as poverty world poverty
goes down like insane stats i saw about
that recently about
how the world health organizations made
like
50 years of progress in the last 15
years or something like that they've
eradicated so much of it
you know over time if you roll that
forward where does the trajectory take
us
takes us to a much more aligned
population
yeah i love that i mean it's such a
such a hopeful
ideology really isn't it this idea that
for many of us clearly not everyone in
the world but for many of us
we're in a position now that we've never
been in before that our ancestors that
even our parents weren't
in so we can now think about why am i
here
how do i wish to spend my time what do i
want out of each day you know
so maybe your grandparents feel
laughable what you what are you thinking
about you think
just gotta you gotta find a way to make
some money get food on the table and
have some shelter at night so it is
it is a lovely thought because actually
evolution is always happening right
we're constantly evolving it's hard to
see it when we're in it
but evolution is happening so maybe we
are revolving into that time period now
where actually
yeah we can fundamentally change the
values
in society and i kind of feel that
you know many things that have happened
in the world over the past years
including
you know the big lockdowns and the the
the sort of
restrictions uh that were put in place
in 2020
they are forcing a lot of these
existential questions to so many of us
you know how are we living our life what
was i
really doing did i enjoy just constantly
chasing
all the time uh you mentioned that um
that the e-word that tiger and his dad
used to use but that word enough i think
is something
that i thought when i opened journal in
the morning and i will often think about
enough
what does it mean what is enough at what
point
can you stop or what point you go yeah i
kind of like
the pace of my life i'm kind of pretty
cool with this
i'm i'm good you know i don't think many
of us ask ourselves that question we're
constantly chasing
more more money more status more fame
more followers
more holidays better holidays but
i think certainly for me and i know many
people share this in 2020 certainly in
the first lockdown
i kind of you know in the uk we had
great weather
during our first lot town in march and
uh
of course i i will acknowledge that
everyone experiences this in a different
way you know i was
i'm in a lucky position where i could do
a lot of my work from home
i was you know i had a garden so my kids
were able to
play in a garden and not be you know
stuck in a studio apartments
right so i i understand that that gives
me a certain lens to which you look at
this
through but i thought wow
actually going for walks or bike rides
every day with my wife and kids there's
some quite nice country paths near where
i live like maybe i don't need to go off
on a beach holiday every three months
to to go and find happiness actually
i realized that actually just spending
time with the people close to me and
actually engaging in
and spending time with them in nature
each day
i'm not sure i've ever felt this happy
or this content
this is what it is all about so i don't
know
i i kind of feel there's a lot going on
in the world at the moment
and the hope is i i think you you
possibly share this from what you're
saying the hope is that
actually maybe something beautiful is
going to come out on the other side of
this where we think
actually what is really important in
life is it money famous success or is it
love relationships compassion
do you know what i mean it's kind of um
it's kind of what i spend most of my
time thinking about these days what what
what does that all mean
and can we get there because i think we
can
if you can't be happy with a coffee you
won't be happy with a yacht
that's something i picked up last year
from naval final thing man i have to
bring this up
have you seen the new covers of
cosmopolitan this
this is healthy wellness does not come
in one size cover have you seen this
i haven't has it just come out okay so
it's a variety of different body shapes
of women there's 11 different covers on
it
um there's a rugby player on there who's
obviously like much more muscular than
usual and there's
a sprinter on there and there's some
plus-sized girls one of whom is
in a wheelchair so it's the full gamut
now
people are overweight as far as i'm
concerned can be perfectly happy and
live fulfilled lives i absolutely do not
think
that fat shaming people achieves
anything but categorizing someone who is
obese
as healthy is dangerous being morbidly
obese
is not healthy and it has never been
healthy and the condition of
good physical and mental health
especially when actively maintained by a
proper diet
exercise and the avoidance of risky
behavior is the definition
of wellness it's the complete opposite
so i pulled up this
meta-analysis on the association of
all-cause mortality
with overweight and obesity using
standard body mass index categories
so relative to normal weight both
obesity of all grades
and grades two and three obesity were
associated with significantly higher
all-cause mortality
so that's a 95 correlation between being
obese
and dying sooner from everything that
makes being fat
the most wellness reducing thing that
you can do
cosmopolitan telling people that this is
healthy isn't just wrong
as far as i'm concerned it's dangerous
and stupid like cosmopolitan are
purposefully misleading their audience
so that they can jump on the newest
trend of signaling that their body
positive
like imagine if one of your patients
came in to see you and said dr
chatterjee
i've been gaining a lot of weight
recently but this role model on the
front
of the cover of cosmopolitan said that
it's healthy
and well they're in wellness and health
to be morbidly obese like i don't
understand
how we've managed to get ourselves so
confused to a world
where we can't criticize someone for
their body weight which again i don't
agree with
but we can't criticize someone with a
body weight because it's going to hurt
their feelings
but we can call over being morbidly
obese
well or healthy so that that
is going to set a trend for people down
the line surely that's the more
dangerous route
yeah look i haven't seen that and i'm
definitely going to make an effort over
tomorrow or the next completes actually
have a look and see what's going on
there
but this is something that i sort of
tackled in the introduction of
my new book which i decided to write on
weight loss or healthy sustainable
weight loss
for a number of reasons and one of the
reasons is that i think it has got
to this point in society as you say for
some people not everyone
where you can't have an honest
conversation i
am against fat shaming we can absolutely
have compassion
full compassion and no prejudice against
people who are carrying
excess body weights okay no i
absolutely but some people go
one step further these are some
proponents in the body positivity
movement
we'll go one step further and say
actually it is
i should say completely okay because
okay can mean many things to different
people but
it is completely healthy to carry lots
of excess weight and you don't need to
do anything about it
and that's where certainly as a medical
doctor i actually have a sort of
split from what some of them are saying
i agree with a lot of it which is let's
embrace people with who they are let's
love people for who they are let's not
call them lazy or lacking willpower or
blame them there are many complex
reasons behind why people end up being
the weight that they are that is
there's there's really good science on
that it is not as simplistic as it's
made out to be
but we still have a responsibility to
say listen
if you carry this much excess body fat
you are
increasing the likelihood of you know
poor health outcomes from a variety of
different conditions so
it's everything is decided now chris
it's it's got a polarizing extreme it's
like we go
we we take a point of um compassion and
not fat shaming which is great
and take it to an extreme which is it's
completely okay we should never tell
anyone
who carried excess weight that actually
would be in their health interests
to reduce it and i sort of there's a
couple of paragraphs in the book where i
actually mention this and say listen
i get i get that we don't want a fat
shame
and i'm very supportive of that
but we also need to start to look at the
science and actually be honest with
people and say listen
i get it that it's been tough for you
and you've ended up in this position
right you're a great person your
identity is not that you are
fat right you have an identity that
you're a kind compassionate individual
yes
you also are carrying excess body fat at
the moment that's why i think the
language we use
particularly the language we talk about
to ourselves which gave us a big part of
one section of the book which is to try
and help people go the way you talk
about yourself it's really really
important
some people say i am fat they're
wrapping up their whole sense of
identity in this idea of being fat so
actually
to lose their fats in some ways would be
to lose
part of their self and who they are um
now for some people it's not a problem
right but for some people it is
there is really good research chris now
uh i don't know if you know the aces
trial that
um dr vincent valetti did about a decade
or so ago
where he showed a very strong
correlation between people who've had
adverse childhood experiences like
physical or emotional abuse as kids
and obesity a very very strong
correlation and i share in the book a
case study that
i remember really well this um
this i think she was 16 or 17 when when
i first saw her
um in clinic uh and i got to know her as
a patient
and now actually it was later than that
maybe she was 18 or 19 and she was
really struggling to lose weight
she tried everything and i was spending
time
trying to understand what was going she
never was overweight before till about
the age of 16.
and then it turned out that actually she
had she was in an abusive relationship
uh just after she turned 16.
and i really felt there was something to
unpick there and we
you know i i sent her to a therapist to
get some up and it turned out that
actually for her what happened
was that it was a defense mechanism for
her so
she was basically i don't want to be in
this position of being in an abusive
relationship again
if i put on body fat she thought
i am no longer going to be attracted to
men desirable
less desirable i'm going to be unseen
and actually when we started to address
that unpick it and it was
it was challenging to unpick that
actually
then the weight loss started to come
sustainably healthily
in a way that made her feel good and the
reason i bring that up
is we should have full compassion
for her we don't need to blame her until
she's being lazy
and she's not following you know as
brothers are saying you know do this for
the nhs it's hold on a minute
she was trying her best to
do it but she was she hadn't identified
the right problem so she was trying to
solve the wrong
problem once we helped to identify the
right issue for her
and then she started getting help she
was able to lose that excess body fat
and going back to your first point
around
the cosmoponto covers which i will say
to be clear i have not seen them yet
so it's very hard for me to comment on
something i've not seen
but i don't think we should be promoting
it and saying
this is healthy i think we should be
there is
nuance to all of these things right
that's the word that's precisely the
word that i was thinking about man like
there are gradations between fat shaming
and calling being morbidly obese healthy
like it's not just and the fact of the
matter is that it's such an absolutist
media
circus out there that it can't be it's
got to be either
you want to kill all fat people and
they're worthless
or you have to be completely behind it
deny
any of the incredibly robust claims from
all walks of medicine that show that
being obese is not good for your health
or your longevity
like there is a middle point in there
where we can
accept people we can say this doesn't
make you any less of a person any
different of a person
but it would be much better for your
health outcomes if you were able to lose
some weight
and i i don't know if anybody i'd be
interested to hear in the comments
does anybody actually think that
cosmopolitan
genuinely believe that this is healthy
or
does everybody see through the glass
front door which is just
this is the new sort of newsworthy body
part
positivity movement that we're all on
the back of like i'm all for jim shark
varying the range of models that they
use
but they're not claiming that this is
the optimal health or wellness outcome
that you should have
the difference and the the line i think
that's been crossed here by cosmopolitan
which you'll
see when you finally get to see it is it
says this is
wellness this is healthy like those
words are directly under people who are
not
well or healthy i i don't know i don't
know
yeah it's it's you know it's so
interesting chris because
um as we mentioned just before we
we started recording
this this new book on on weight loss
that uh that i've written
i didn't go into lightly i didn't need
to do it frankly the truth is i didn't
need to go into this area
like i i you know my first few books
are making really good impacts i'm
talking about promoting health
well-being
physical health mental health emotional
health the
easy thing to do would it be not to
touch the weight loss
right because it's so controversial
and i don't need to i didn't need to
yeah it is but you know why i did
is actually part of the thing that
you're bringing up with these
with these magazine covers is that
i've been seeing patients for 20 years
what i have seen
as a gp you see everything right you you
have
you well i'm not saying you see
absolutely everything but you see a lot
more than
potentially other specialties and what i
mean by that is let's say if you're a pt
if you're if you're
um if you you know you're a personal
trainer
you are likely to see people who believe
that actually working out hard is going
to help them lose weight
right they're coming in with that belief
system in place
and therefore you're going to see the
subset of people who really believe
that's the way that's going to help them
and you're going to have your own
experience of what works and what
doesn't work
right and that's completely fine if
you're a psychologist
you're probably going to see people
who've got complex emotional issues
around weights and foods
and there you're going to be you're
going to have potentially a bias
around that this is kind of the main
issue that i'm seeing when i see people
who are trying to lose
weight i will have my own bias because
i'm
a human being and i've got my own
experiences but i think as a gp what
happens is that we tend to see people
from all different walks who are
struggling with all kinds of different
things so we see
the full gamut and i thought you know
what
i really feel i've got something unique
to share here in a slightly different
tone and a different way that i think
will help a lot of people out there who
are being shamed
who are being made to feel bad about
themselves
who do think that they are failures and
that they can't stick to any plan
but at the same time are being told and
are thinking well actually maybe it's
okay
to have a bmi of 40. i don't know well
hold on a minute
it's not either raw we can be medically
accurate scientifically accurate and
have full compassion at the same time
and you know the truth is that this book
was probably the hardest book that i
wrote
because trying to keep the the ideas
simple
trying to make them actionable trying to
get the tone right
was something that took a lot of time to
do
um but it's partly part of the reason
for doing this because i actually think
there's a lot of people out there who
are being mis-served
and are being made to feel like failures
and
worthless um so yes i mean i don't know
if that made sense or not it's kind of
no
thoughts i was thinking through that no
it really does man and i think
sadly at the moment we have two
competing factions neither of whom are
doing a massive amount of good
for people who should or want to lose
weight
you have one side which is making a
judgment on them and their worth as an
individual about their weight
and you have another side which is
giving them advice
and a level of encouragement
which is literally going to kill them
sooner
neither of those situations are
fantastic like
i've just given you the most robust
meta-analysis that i could find that
says it's an
obesity is an all-cause mortality risk
and any doctor knows this as well which
i'm sure that you will
and on the flip side it's not we're not
11 years old and it's 1972.
like you don't just call the fat kid in
the playground fat and
he's the fat one like we're a lot more
sophisticated than that or at least i
like to think that we're a lot more
sophisticated than that now
but yeah man again these tighter and
tighter circles
that we go through i hope that we end up
arriving at a place
that is much more capable of sort of
accepting nuance and doesn't
just see everything as this bipolar
situation but i wonder whether it's a
function of
social media it was seeing more and more
echo chambers
and uh bifurcating in terms of the way
that people see their politics and
it's not surprising that we're seeing it
in terms of health as well we see
everywhere and
have you seen the social dilemma yes
yeah and it's
you know of course you know a lot
there's chris there's critiques of that
but i
i you know i i enjoyed watching i
certainly the fundamental
concepts of that in terms of the way
these algorithms work the way they feed
you to more and more extreme views on
the things
they think you are going to want to
engage in i found super interesting and
it explains
so much about
the lack of nuance we now have in
society the lack of context it's like
you know i've done a day of interviews
um as as
a part of a book promo and yeah most of
them have been really enjoyable but a
few of them are very much
like you know you know so are you pro
uh you know you know i don't know let's
say are you pro intimate and fasting
are you are you pro low carb but hold on
a minute and i
i i say look i'm giving you the same
answer i get in the last one but
it depends for some people restricting
their eating window
is game changing for them and works in
the context of their lifestyle
for them it's brilliant but for someone
else it may not work so well they may
not feel great on it
it may not work in the context of the
rest of their lifestyle
and i i would keep saying the same thing
which is and what i try and do in my
book as i try and help people determine
what is the right approach for them and
i feel as a doctor that my job isn't to
identify with one particular campus to
go wait a minute
i'm a generalist i'm an expert
journalist my job is to
see all of it okay which bits are
relevant here for this patient
in front of me which bits are relevant
for this particular reader like we were
talking about brian mckenzie before
which breathing technique does this
client who's come to work with me
need is it the vimhof or is it
buteyko type breathing or is it neither
is it something else entirely
and it's that nuance and context that
gets lost
everywhere certainly on social media but
i think in media
at large these days we're losing that
context
you'll have seen the paradox of choice
barry schwartz's
ted talk i'm sure which is basically it
explains why we don't like having an
overload of choices
we think that it allows us to maximize
our utility as a perfect rational human
being
by having 75 different pairs of genes
but
actually the research suggests that
would be easier if we just had three
different
types of genes that we could buy because
we always feel like we could have made a
better decision
and i wonder whether this is a function
of information overload
whether the fact that we have access to
so many different strategies available
on the internet
previously i i don't know but 50 years
ago i can't imagine that there was
this many diets available in the
knowledge bank of the lay person
and it certainly wasn't available at the
push of a button on google what diet is
best for losing weight
millions millions and millions of hit
results and videos on youtube
so that paradox of choice inevitably
means that people think right
you're the expert you must know out of
all of these ones out of all of the two
million different diets that there are
you must know what the best one is
so you tell us what the best one is yeah
but it goes beyond that actually the
wider point for me
is also
it's about autonomy and agency
and in the penultimate page at the
bottom remember it was going off to
print in september
and i remember emailing penguin urgently
saying look stop it i've got to add
um there's one there's a couple of lines
i need to add to go wrong
yeah it's a page just before that and i
i can't i won't say i mean i can't get
it verbatim but
i put here and when people ask you what
plan you're following you can tell them
that you no longer follow other people's
plans because you've been empowered
to create your own hey you got that you
got that word perfect well done mate
was it so yeah it was kind of and i
think
to some people it's like yeah okay
what's the big deal about that but for
some people
that will be game changing because it's
it is
this is what and this comes from these
these 20 years of clinical experience
chris which is
a different things work for different
people but anybody
can make short-term change the truth is
if someone is looking to
lose weight now you could probably pick
up any diet book off the shelf
right and if you follow it meticulously
for the next three weeks
you will probably lose some weight
probably
right but i don't think that's what
people are really after
certainly that's what my patients tell
me what people are really after is
transformation
is real consistent long-term change they
want to
feel different in themselves they want
to feel better about themselves and want
better self-esteem they want change
that's still going on in march and april
and
may in june
next january they don't just want the
drop of dress size in two weeks
and so i don't feel my role as a doctor
is to tell
my patient what to do i've never told a
patient to give up smoking before
right and what i mean by that is i'm i
don't feel as a fellow human being i've
got a right to tell them to give up
smoking what i have a right to do is
if they ask me for my help my job is to
say listen
smoking in my view is doing a b c
and d to you at the moment right so if
you want these health outcomes i think
not smoking would be beneficial for you
but if that individual
says yeah doc i understand what you're
telling me
but i get so much enjoyment out smoking
my cigarettes
that i'm prepared to put up with those
risks that you just told me about
yeah i'm gonna keep going thanks as a
doctor but as a fellow human being i
think okay as long as i feel that you
have
understood what i've said and i've done
a good job at communicating
with you what you're perfectly entitled
to do that
right and and the point i'm trying to
make is
you can have someone tell you what the
best diet is right
and you can start going down that train
for two or three weeks and try and
follow it
but at some point you've got to take
ownership and go
you know what i like certain components
of this i'm not sure i like that one and
you have to start
turning it from someone else's plan into
being your plan you've got to have that
agency and that self-awareness and that
knowledge to know each day hey you know
what when i eat like this i feel better
i can drop weight i can uh have more
energy
when i don't i don't feel so good in and
it
it's something i'm really passionate
about is empowering an individual to
know themselves
so actually you're not following the
doctor chatterjee plan in his latest
book
you know what you're hopefully having me
hold your hand and guide you through
this journey and go you might want to
consideration
this this is work for this patient this
is work for that patient and then say
but this is what i think you should do
now
start off with this and then figure out
how to adapt it yourself and i
i really feel we've given up that agency
to other people
to experts and that may surprise people
because i am
one of these so-called experts but i
actually think
there is something about being an expert
but at the same time i think we've
over worshiped the expert
i kind of feel we're all kind of
sovereign individuals who actually
if we really tune into who we are we
get a really good sense of what's
working for us and what's not working
for us
so my goal with every patient that i see
or for every reader of my books or every
listener of my podcast my goal is always
the same which is
can i help you understand yourself
better
so you're going to make better choices
not because
i told you to but because you want to
that's the most robust way to enact
behavior change to understand the
fundamentals
to actually have knowledge and finally
with the internet we've
removed the gateways previously that
would have restricted people from having
access to this
so yeah man i i totally get it and i
agree as well
feel great lose weight will be linked in
the show notes below
go and pick it up on amazon if you want
there will be a link there you'll be
supporting the podcast at no extra
cost to yourself if you go and get
yourself a copy from there where else
should
people go to check out your work
listen whatever people are into i i
guess uh
you know this is the there's four books
out there if people are interested one
on stress one on general health one and
behavior change
i'm on social media channels probably
instagram is the most prominent for me i
guess
at dr chastity that's
d-r-c-h-a-t-t-e-r-j-e
and if people like podcasts like yours
uh mine's called feel better live more
you have set out every wednesday on
usual places and on youtube
boom i love it man everything will be
linked in the show notes below we're
gonna have to do this again i really
enjoyed it mate
me too chris thanks very much for having
me on mate and uh can't wait till next
[Music]
time
you